I don't know how you've done it was down  the barrel you line up side and not  until you're ready you put your finger  on the trigger and you shoot  there they go  [Music]  how much you tell me name  why are you want Bushwick I like here  there's like a whole army out there  that's killing people do you know what's  going on they declared martial law not  just here everywhere  I need you to help I can't do this  five seconds okay  whose recently intercepted by government  officials Texas even from the United  States base so much position they think  we won't buy that the word supposed to  be something going welcome to New York  stupid money  some people know better than to stick  around in a war zone  helicopters tanks you don't remember the  seventy US Army is evacuating people on  here we get out of here it's on a blind  eye boys the tough we need to stick  together but we need to go now  [Music]  we're not gonna make it are we I get one  block at a time  [Music]  you  you